daniel leray bonsoir bonsoir heureux de
vous retrouver il ya eu je vous dis
comme je le disais rêver comme les
connaître il ya eu les élections et
beaucoup de choses mal à essayer de
reprendre avec régularité cette
chronique les gens apprécient surtout le
fait tellement beau un voyant de lyre le
temps de nous parler de deuxième livre
une jeune montréalaise perrine leblanc
oui qui avait connu beaucoup de succès
avec son premier la lance malabo oui
beaucoup de succès avec son premier
c'était l'homme blanc ça se passait dans
les goulags soviétiques écriture très
très ciselée elle avait lu le prix du
gouverneur général le grand prix du
livre de montréal aussi hélas ce qui est
surprenant c'est qu'on est complètement
mais dans un autre univers
ça commence en gaspésie dans un petit
village qui s'appelle mal à bourdon
village imaginaire et on assiste à une
série de meurtres sur des jeunes filles
au monde
il ya un côté très le tout à fait et
c'est tout à fait réussie et là vous
arrivez dans la deuxième partie
complètement autre chose
autre ton aussi on se retrouve à
montréal on est vraiment là aujourd'hui
en fait en 2012
particulièrement printemps érables et
tout et on assiste à une grande histoire
d'amour entre un jeune parent fumeur est
une jeune étudiante
c'est extrêmement sensuelle s'il n'y
avait pas ça du tout dans le premier
roman c'est très différent mais en même
temps la plume tout aussi ciselés et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle est en
lice pour le prix en france le prix
françoise sagan qui a été créé en 2010
pour honorer la mémoire de françoise
sagan et donc c'est vraiment à
surveiller le prix sera remis au début
du mois de juin et elle avait gagné
avec la blanc le grand prix du livre de
montréal oui en tout cas qu'on bâtit
l'île de ré au ghana n'a donc ces
régions est d'amener en 80 plus tout à
fait oui on reste d'une certaine façon à
montréal whitla prochain oui ça
s'appelle la petite communiste qui ne
souriait jamais intimés ordinaires tout
en lola lafon qui s'est inspiré d'un
personnage qu'on connaît bien montréal a
fallu les plus anciens ceux en 1976 donc
nadia comaneci cette petite vraiment
prodige de 14 ans athlète qui va
vraiment éblouir tout le monde aux jeux
olympiques par sa grâce et notre
parfaite qui va devenir une espèce du
compte les petites filles vont tout
vouloir limiter devenir une petite nadia
glomel d'ailleurs plaint bien à hull est
tout à fait remis en cause alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le lit le
sujet du lycée comment et à quel prix
nadia comaneci est elle devenue une
championne
et qu'est-il advenu d'elle après on va
la suivre jusqu'en 1990 après sa
défection aux états unis alors qu'elle
est vraiment devenu ce qu'on appelle une
star déchue
c'est pas une biographie c'est un roman
mais l'auteur lola lafon respecter les
dates les événements les lieux tout soit
le juste combler un peu les trous par la
fiction ce qui est intéressant c'est que
l'auteur elle est née en france elle a
grandi en partie en roumanie sous
ceausescu et elle retrace le parcours de
nadia dans tous à quel point s'est fait
manipuler par le système en place
on voit son corps malmené par vraiment
tous ces entraînements excessif
privation de nourriture sur fondue
formation de médicaments et surtout
quand elles arrivent à la puberté
elle ne veut pas accepter de grossir de
grandir elle est dépressif suicidaire
les médias disent ça y est elle est
devenue une femme elle a perdu sa magie
et c'est ça qui est troublant dans l'est
de voir comment elle a été
instrumentalisée ou lui a refusé de
devenir une femme et on lui a volé sa
vie lola lafon la petite communiste qui
nous sur nous
souriait pardon jamais oui en lice aussi
avec la labour pour le prix françoise à
une suggestion complète sur notre site
internet et tout ça merci daniel
l'horaire nicolas bientôt merci